[Music]
or award sale news Oh submitted by Sam I
am a middle school student with ADHD
received an award at an assembly which
later got two teachers fired what
Wow what kind of award assisted
offensive like the biggest jackass
Awards or something yeah like something
like yeah well I'll give you guys
clearly ADHD the hyper award the most
energetic award because it got two
teachers fired so it's probably [ __ ]
up it says most likely to not be at all
they can even control it as [ __ ] up
lots of [ __ ] you're so [ __ ] - - yeah
why are you giggling doing funny so it's
funny cuz it's so inappropriate like
what the [ __ ] you ever do that you
[ __ ] walk
it wasn't one of the intent yeah not an
entire assembly the whole school that's
like that's like a kid in a wheelchair
the last to finish the mile run that's
[ __ ] on they're so festive like Louis
run or you know what it's like the
lights what he could so stupid
believable like what is I think it's a
lazy eye they're like the most not
likely to see straight award no but for
the person who never looks you in the
eye Awards about the falsity teachers
came up with this brilliant idea all I
know is that what came out of this was
that two teachers have been dismissed
from the school did they know that she
had ADHD though or was it just like this
disruptive student you have to tell your
the teachers the school like any medical
conditions or pills or anything have
your contain okay because if it was like
they didn't know and they just thought
that this person was a crazy kid no so
the mom was so upset when she when her
daughter came home and saw her 14 year
old daughter came home which is evil
yeah was she like yeah I was so like
naive at a young age and teachers were
like God you know I mean like what they
said it was like there's no other way of
looking at the world so they gave me
something like that maybe internally I'd
be like oh this is weird but okay there
everyone's happy okay yeah
this award let's note if you were like
17 but this person is like 14 years old
- yeah I maybe get it if she was 4 cuz I
wore that I always got with either most
humorous or most improvement and and so
I would be crazy happy right but then my
mom would tell me you know what most
improvement means right that just means
you're the worst person and now you're
not so it's pretty much the same thing
but I'm still happy when I got it dad
that's what your mom says because I
didn't really improve talking about
[ __ ] asian asian dude most improvement
just means you did better than last time
but just means I went from an F to a D
the guy didn't like which was the worst
person in class a lot of people get most
improvement Awards oh really
I never got any [ __ ] Awards I think
everybody gets the what like the
participation award
like where do we get that [ __ ] I didn't
participate I got nothing - I never got
a point really all right everyone oh
what's so [ __ ] funny all that is a
new generation maybe whatever you
generation granny heaven no no look at
school where it's just like you're like
worried though given to everybody yeah I
think on school term have enough budget
to print out that many one okay but the
reason why I think I got a lot of
teachers didn't like me was because I
had the worst grades in class like I
didn't do [ __ ] is [ __ ] the cracking
jokes all the time I'm making them look
that you probably disrupted a lot every
time no I wasn't very disruptive I
didn't do [ __ ] I don't do nothing that
was [ __ ] dude i disrupted but on the
you wanna start testing i always scored
the highest so every [ __ ] week I would
get I would have a meeting about me is I
listen if he's actually not dumb if
Angie just doesn't want to do it I don't
want to do at those meetings - yeah it's
just like because I think it's like
frustrating for an educator you know
they made this like just to the [ __ ]
work
this is not like we can't do it we just
think it's done I don't won't do this
but back then they didn't know anything
about ADB and ADHD and like how to you
know just teaching back them wasn't the
same you'd be really cool about what if
we just gave them a [ __ ] bicycle like
a standstill bicycle it could spell on
that was try that out and it actually
worked
yeah see that would help out a lot
justify a cinema [ __ ] by nah you know
it would be great nothing they were
getting out of kids like those fidget
spinners that now
every everyone has one of those
[ __ ] now yeah but what happened
was the fittest bidders it did the exact
opposite exactly a good I picked a
teacher and after-school program like
she was just like yeah this sucks
because I meant for like autistic kids
kids of ADHD like they can't focus and
cool so they privately like do it so
then somehow it helps them focus and
their school works I don't know like
everyone started having it so just
defeated the purpose of what it was
meant to do it's like their clogs now
did you spit it out with the positive
back in our day and I got people do
trips with them not it's just a very
amount of all site yeah sooner I've seen
people spin like ah no no no really
already
oh wait so the little skateboard special
effect at all through the tactics were
still that [ __ ] skills ok still can't do
that [ __ ] I've gone with a pencil
weather that I was really good at the
grind and all kinds of [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
that was called a push of it you know
that was actual move
BAM Holly you feel like you just like to
get to the dears Cuba
Liv I did Holly Korean so I'm not sure
if the daughter to go home happy there's
no much better sure she did but I just
know that the mom was just really upset
because she's like the you know I was
humiliating from for my child and then
she was like these teachers are
constantly calling me and complaining
about my kid that she doesn't pay
attention in school and then they're
gonna give her an award for it like that
makes no sense this is just like the
what seems fantastic yeah more likely to
not pay attention
maybe I'm just gonna give like a
positive spin on this real quick maybe
they have a dope relationship with the
kid like they actually like because I
give me at my Japanese teacher Santos
intake she [ __ ] sent me to the corner
to count to 100 and Japanese all the
time and I could not do it okay but at
the end of the year even though I had a
C in her class she actually liked me a
lot and so we would always like talk and
joke and she would you know clown me all
the time but it was like she was
bullying me we actually had like
probably the best relationship and it's
not even I wasn't the best student but
do you think she would have done that in
front of all the party Emily assembly or
in front of the clock didn't matter she
called on me 24/7 because I feel like I
understand that
but that's usually more like between the
two of you like no one else really knows
that you guys get along like that
usually like cuz that had relationships
like that was teachers too but not
understand I give this person the
benefit about because I do know that
students have very specific
relationships with teachers like mr.
Tavares in high school right
he called me David slow all the time
every day I was loved David slow because
I've never showed up all done so I'm not
in change
exactly so I never I never really like
got mad at that stuff but he now works
very cool with each other you know me I
don't know how the daughter feels about
it but I just know what the mom had sent
so she brought it up to the attention of
the school and that's when the school
took immediate action instead these
teachers will not be coming back next
year remember when they had cartoons of
kids like wearing dunce caps and sitting
in front of the class and being
humiliated I don't think that happened
in my generation but I remember seeing
it on cartoons and TV shows and [ __ ] so
they must have done it like I don't know
like 10 years before us so they used to
humiliate the [ __ ] out of students all
the time right so now it's like
different they don't do that no more
because they realize it doesn't [ __ ]
help that's true back in my first high
school Cerritos our campus security were
actual former correctional officers so
they dealt with gangsters so when they
saw those kid gangsters right they never
really took us really seriously and one
of them found out that I was a dub so
she would always call I'm watching you
I'm watching you what are you going to
do rob a house and it was like they
dealt with actual gangsters all the time
to the point where all these little
street gangs didn't really give a [ __ ]
about them and though it embarrassed me
for my friends because in your little
group you think okay this might clicks
on hello heart so you're not and I
thought that was really really cool and
I ended up being really really close
with her that is me kind of thinking
about like interpersonal relationships
that you have the teachers I mean if
that's not the case it's not the case
but you know just to kind of put that
out there but there are said that there
are relationships like that to where the
kids not the best student but they had
really don't believe but she was hurt by
it right the kid that's the thing I
don't know how the key of reaction was
we just know what the mom yeah I don't
know no matter what if you have a
condition like let's say you deaf
and then you get an award for least
likely to [ __ ] in here or some [ __ ] like
that
like a fat listener like like let's say
you get let's say let's say you're
awarded the man dinner you're like I'm
bad listener award or whatever the round
of applause award is please like they
are here huh doesn't [ __ ] listen
yeah the mom I said this quote my goal
is to make sure that this horrible event
never happens to another kid again as a
parent it is my job to protect my child
from being humiliated and bullied
especially when the bully is her teacher
making fun of any disability is not
acceptable maybe it's because they don't
view ADHD as a real disability yeah I
think it's easier when you see like
someone with no legs or no hands again
if they can that's a disability because
you could see it a lot of conditions and
stuff they can't see it right so someone
with a TD or ADHD you just think they're
being annoying do people know the source
of people who have ADHD or like what is
the reason is that I know I love it what
is it I had ADHD growing up and anxiety
but during our time though when that
thing just came out everybody was
labeling every [ __ ] thing really kids
just have energy like that's normal
right like kids are supposed to have
energy but then some kids just are crate
yeah actually if you actually think they
invented exactly they gave me ADHD too
and I think they actually invented it
because teachers sucked at teaching so
instead of blaming the teachers just
easier to single out the three kids that
aren't learning the way that there's
they wanted to learn it was during a
time when our school was like 40 [ __ ]
kids in one class and there's only one
teacher and like both parents are
working no attention from parents the
home is [ __ ] up that's the you know
norm I think when we were growing up I
mean when when I heard of other students
stories about like them being diagnosed
with ADHD like their parents or their
families would just refuse to believe
that they have it and they're like oh
you're fine like there's nothing wrong
with does my mom and
I'm glad my mom didn't give me no pills
and [ __ ] did they treat you any
different when you're in school I had
like David syndrome where I stuck around
all the time not do any other work I had
no idea what you're talking about but
then when I took that Patti taught me
when I took the test like I would kill
anything
so I'll kill her on the test and then
the teachers always was found that wish
they was bringing up to assistant
principal me my sister principal ash had
a really good relationship so they would
bring in these evaluators and then one
of them had to take the IQ test to
figure out like what's going on and then
I also had to meet with the psychologist
it was a psychologist for the school
district and she's the one that
diagnosed me with a DD and ADHD with
both and then I don't know if they
treated me differently afterwards but I
do remember her recommending my mom to
get me these medications and my mom so
listed see like [ __ ] that they're not
gonna so she can start performing these
exorcisms on me with incense all right
hey that's a lot better though because I
had a friend who's yeah I was on
adderall and she's taking massive doses
and she's not a normal person
yeah let me click that not normal sure
her mind just doesn't operate in a way
where people can relate to her it's just
gone you know it also kind of makes me
wonder too like if they had seen let's
say like you're in my case right [ __ ]
around but clearly like when you do like
these the state tests showed that we do
have a higher level of intelligence like
what would have happened if our parents
really understood what was going on and
they could have confident I wish they
weren't you know because I didn't know
what to do this we would do these tests
right dot dot one of the first kids done
I'm sitting there like this that was me
actually took SATs and I scored perfect
on some of them yeah so I'm like this is
easy but it just wasn't taught in a way
that was understandable to me so I'm
just [ __ ] around like yeah clowning
on teachers are [ __ ] hmm anyone who
going on taking news fans hope you guys
liked that episode remember to follow
our personal social medias and of course
if you want to watch more videos my to
go where to go your cos occurs right up
there
[Music]